nice to meet you all and today I'll be
talking about uh one of the cases that
we have built for insurance and uh we'll
talk about the problem itself initial
State uh we'll talk about the solution
and we'll talk specifically uh what are
the key points of the solution and then
we'll talk about uh what are the
benefits of it and how maybe you can use
it
so uh to introduce myself
I'm hitting big data and Mild grid
Dynamics I'm principal architect and
responsible for sophisticated programs
implementation
and today I'll be your speaker
all right and before we'll start uh
quick question
how many of you have worked in Insurance
sector maybe you can raise your hands
oh
I see many many hands all right so
um this is a good case and maybe you can
share your experience after my talk so
let's talk and a little bit about it
so uh initial state
our customer was hosting on premises
uh in the private Data Center
the data animal platform uh that was
built
um was quite Legacy with a lot of
um
complexities permission issues with a
lot of
um
special cases and the way how they were
handled
as you can see a number of ml models
were not that high which just about of
30 models and this is was the key
problem of the business uh they wanted
to scale drastically and have more than
100 models handling specific business
cases but the purposes platform was
pretty much limited and that's why they
were considering to have a platforming
program built everything from scratch
and they were considering to go to the
cloud
so ah to just outline the challenges
the primary challenge was very high cost
of ownership and very long time to
Market
uh any model which was developed on on
top of on-premises platform
was kind of hard to test to run any kind
of user acceptance testing and then
release to production
and also since the prob well the
platform itself was built
um actually the implementation of the
on-premises platform start back in
2015's uh the platform was outdated and
it was very hard to
um on board any new capabilities on top
of the platform
and obviously the technical stack was
Legacy one and also was a one of the
reasons of long time to Market
and uh many of you know that insurance
sector is kind of a place where you have
a lot of permissions to be configured
with special treatment of PA data with
[Music]
um
uh what is strict security rules the way
how uh the data is being processed in
the company same was here uh security
compliance was very strict and
um
the client uh was very interested if
they are migrating to the cloud how the
security compliance may stay as is but
uh
um the but actually the number of
limitations or easiness of engineering
to work with the platform uh will be
much higher than it was uh on top of the
on-premise platform
so ah having all these key points as a
Baseline uh we started our
platform implementation uh in terms of
the architecture in the platform
and uh we were
um we're discussing uh a lot of cases
how we can go either Cloud native or
Cloud agnostic and maybe you can help me
with understanding how many of you have
implemented Cloud agnostic Solutions in
the clouds
and the rest I guess have implemented
Cloud native right
I think so all right so and uh this is
the case
um if you would like to be Cloud
agnostic
um you have to invest extra efforts just
to uh build uh application layer or
platform and application layer uh which
is relatively easy to migrate from one
cloud provider to another cloud provider
uh but in case of our customer the speed
of development was a key Point that's
why we went mostly Cloud native with
some specific Services which which are
Cloud agnostic
and typically
um the way how
um we are dealing with our customers we
give them a choice whether they would
like to be Cloud native or Cloud
agnostic and I would say two out of
three customers are definitely
interested to be Cloud native
so ah the Legacy architecture was not
very sophisticated
there are cases when
um either insurance agent or customer
itself works with the uh infrastructure
I mean with the Services itself
and the infrastructure was quite a
linear in terms of
several models deployed on premises
under load balancer and
serving two types of requests either
insurance agent is calculating insurance
Price and issues Insurance to the
customer or the customer itself can do
it for instance Via mobile phone
um and uh there were a lot of challenges
with this architecture uh just because
uh the way how models were stored in
repository tested on the environment and
then released the production uh was
fully manual operation and what this was
the primary challenge uh why time to
Market uh was significantly high and why
uh the cost actually development teams
have to wait before all the manual
operations are applied before the model
runs in production
and the customer was very interested to
consider another solution where these
all steps can be automated
and uh actually the challenges itself
are like deployment of new model
or
issuing a hardware uh in on-premises
cluster before deploying a new model uh
were
pretty manual operations so this is a
kind of Gyro request to issue a new
hardware
uh which will be dedicated specifically
to the new business functionality
uh once the hardware is there in the
data center you can start releasing to
production and
um
these are obvious manual operations that
cannot be avoided and can't be estimated
uh in on-premise cluster
uh that's why actually the entire cicd
was not fully automated and that's why
um actually
um Cloud implementation
should be not just lift and shift but
full rework from the scratch uh where we
are delivering uh fully automated
platform and ability to manage model
life cycle from the code but not
manually
so these are technical challenges and
um before talking about uh
what was the solution specifically I
would like to talk a little bit about
several key points of the solution uh
which were addressed in the cloud
architecture
um there is such kind of thing like
feature development
in different
Industries future development is
pretty much different but in each other
sector uh there is a well-defined
project uh sorry a well-defined process
how features may look like how they are
calculated and what data is used to
create features
and I'll break a couple of examples
let's say you'd like to issue a driver
Insurance vehicle insurance sorry
um the driver profile which is used to
calculate the insurance Price with all
specific Fields like a number of car
incidents the each of the driver
what is the experience these are pretty
well defined features and they are not
changing from year to year
obviously there might be some
kind of new insights and some slight
data changes but overall uh feature
development in insurance is well defined
this is number one second feature
development itself is the way
is maybe done by data engineering team
made done by data science team and also
in production there should be a way how
features are created how the serving is
working on top of the features so model
development and production serving both
should have same way of creating
features
and here
in Insurance sector
we were aiming to create one unified way
of creating features so that it can be
used for data engineering teams it can
be reused in data science teams and
obviously it will be the same then
models running in production
and these kind of reusable concept is a
core thing of the platform since it
helps to drastically reduce efforts to
release model to production
and maybe I can bring an example on top
of this architecture of the cloud
platform
so
um let's assume that you would like to
develop a new uh model uh which is
calculating
um cost of the Marine insurance
uh you have identified all the features
that you need
and you have created it for your testing
purposes uh once you have created these
features they are obviously available in
development environment
and uh you have completed your model
development now you would like to move
it to user acceptance testing
environment
and you need somehow these features to
be present also in user acceptance
environment but you don't want these
features to be copied manually or you
don't want this process to be manual
so you may Define these features as just
the uh
python functions then you commit these
python functions and once
the code is there you are creating Peak
package which exactly represents your
feature so here it is this is your
feature it will be used for development
purposes it will be used in production
and we have built a custom application
which is actually a catalog of the
features you can search there you can
see offer you can see what versions of
the feature is available now uh let's
assume that we are going to production
and we need to populate create these
features in production environment we
might do it in batch manner or maybe we
can do it in streaming manner if
required since it's just a python
function
it can it can be reused in any
environment and can create features in
production in automated manner
now we have created these features put
it in our feature store
and let's assume that we are running uh
our we just released our model to
production running there and see that
accidentally we have a new customer
for which we don't have specific
features that's absolutely fine we can
calculate on the Fly just using
um
a model which is running on top of
sagemaker will fetch base data set apply
this function from the Repository
and calculate needed features on the Fly
it will take on around half of the
second to do it end to end but still
fine and still from performance
perspective the client won't see any
delays during the
calculations I mean there won't be
significant delays on the in the mobile
on or on the website
so this is how it works and this is how
it helps to unify uh data pipeline
development feature development and
serving clear
and a few words about architecture
itself
so uh it was running it's actually
running in AWS
um
heavy data computations are running on
top of Emar these are essentially Pi
spark jobs running on top of it
um almost all cases uh doesn't require
uh streaming data processing since
data preparation feature preparation is
um mostly batch in its manner
and if you imagine like typical life
cycle of
customers in Insurance sector you buy an
insurance typically once a year for your
car or household and your next visit to
the insurance company will be in a year
that's why actually the time which the
way how insurance companies are
calculating lifetime value for the
customers significantly high they are
taking the date for the last several
years to see what is TransCore rate and
optimizes
models based on top of this data
and uh serving um let's maybe
specifically talk about serving layer
um the serving player actually
um
is implemented on top of sagemaker uh
all models are running on top of
sagemaker and exposing a rest interface
a number of models can be scaled
and it's not actually Limited
um so we were able to scale drastically
number of models from the point when it
was on premises and then all the
operations migrated to production
um so actually uh
the key Point here is that uh these the
environment is pretty much isolated and
doesn't require specific things to be
available outside of the environment
that's why if a site department wants to
provision uh yet another environment
it's pretty much easy fully automated
and can be done from scratch
uh and actually uh what I wanted to
um like highlight
um about the solution itself
key points and
um
business benefits uh that this solution
has brought
so first of all
the simplification of the solution
helped to
start developing more ml models
uh start to
um like onboard new business use cases
which were significantly costly to
onboard using on-premises platform
uh it's a model development efforts
itself uh were reduced drastically so
you don't need to do many data
preparations on your own uh you don't
need to search specific features or
create them for your testing purposes
many of them already available and you
can just use it
um
also
um
the platform itself helped to separate
the cost across different departments so
if you
um if you would like to run your own
setup of models it can be easily run
using your AWS account and this can be
separated across different different
departments
are unscaling yeah obviously it's it's
it's there and talking about technical
benefits
uh this migration actually helped to
solve
technical debt uh what that was where
there for lasting years of on-premise
platform development
uh since everything was implemented
pretty much from scratch
it helped to
um
take new approaches new technologies
consider how you would like to run it
in the cloud and build everything from
scratch
uh also
[Music]
um
previously Elon promises platform they
development different teams might use
absolutely different approaches
absolutely different technical stack and
that was very high and very it was
introducing High operational costs
supporting it in production
and ah this solution helped to unify the
approach helped to unify technical stack
help to reduce
um
support team which is supporting all the
production uh applications
and finally
talking about development environments
this is a thing that typically many of
our customers are not taking seriously
but this is a key point of
like engineering Comfort developing
anything and we have delivered
development environments which are
separated from production environment
data from production environment is
obfuscated and can be used on
development environment that easily so
this is still
production data uh which is
exactly distributed as a production data
has exactly the same features production
data but name last name email are
obfuscated uh that's why you simply
cannot use this personal data anywhere
but still you can develop all the models
and the data exactly mimics what you
have in real life
and development environment has a lot of
capabilities for instance you can run
specific services in AWS or you can tune
uh types of sagemaker instances that you
you are required to run ml models and it
greatly helps not to do it through a
ticket to Our IT service but it helps
you to do it manually and just reduce
time required to develop a model so this
development environment is very friendly
and all the development teams warmly
um
migrated to the cloud
development platform and
started using it extensively in terms of
new features that our Cloud can provide
so
um these are main achievements of the
platform development
and we are slightly approaching to q a
session and I'm here to help you
hello yeah uh I'm here yeah
um uh thank you for the presentation uh
I'm interested what kind of problems
have you solved in uh Insurance domain
using ml models like the most
interesting ones
so
um
the way how
um
the the program was taking two years
first one is to implement the platform
and second to implement new capabilities
on top of the platform and um second
year problem say second year program uh
was
focused on building personalized
recommendations
uh for
um for specific segments or for audience
of the insurance company so it was more
targeted
recommendations and improved churn
predictions with uh was identifying
whether customer is about to leave the
company
okay thank you yep yep
maybe maybe you can take a microphone
yeah I would like uh
to want uh
uh no worries
I want to know uh how did you implement
uh the version and taking off ml models
uh was it a milli flow or other
technology
yeah great question so
um typically during the development
um uh you need somehow to track the
experiments track the models uh and try
together experiments and model versions
so uh in our case
um I did not mention specifically on the
architecture yes it was ml flow which we
used to track a model version and
experiments which was running for this
specific model and also features that
were used for these experiments that's
why it was uh tracking of model feature
and results of this experiment
okay thank you
um yeah hey uh I guess last piece that I
did not understand is the actual data
science workflow for the data scientists
on the team so they probably use some
notebook environment
and if the features are prepared in
stores in some catalog and like stored
the definition starts as P packages how
how does that work
yeah great question so uh for the
development purposes again same Sage
maker was used
uh and sagemaker is providing jupyter
notebooks
um since you have a catalog of all
features uh you have a catalog of
um python packages supplied with to
these features you can use either this
features already created features or you
can use
use this information just to implement
your own on top of existing features for
instance if you are creating
um driver feature which is like kind of
general information about driver but
then you would like to subtract specific
features about driver and use it for
instance uh for the model which
recommends
um
specific
um I would say for the driver Insurance
recommends different types of insurance
for the vehicle
uh this might be built on top of
existing feature set by implementing
your own feature set and all happens in
sagemaker uh just using uh just using
existing information
implementing it in Sage maker then once
the model is implemented in sagemaker it
goes to
um
it passes a kind of refactoring to be
running as a python executable
then this python executable drops into
web service that can be run on top of
sagemaker and actually this is it it can
be running in production
yeah yeah first of all thank you for the
talk and I have a question concerning
the like the feature that you that are
packed in packages
how you run them do you trigger like 200
like lambdas and process them in the
lambdas which are written to the feature
storage etc etc or like how it's
organized I mean that maybe I missed
yeah yeah this is a great question sorry
yes I missed it in my talk
um so uh feature so uh typically the
pipeline of features which which apply
on the base data set and create features
is not that high so about 10 like 5
between 5 and 15 features and they are
um
this this pipeline is implemented in pi
spark workflow it might be a workflow
which consists of uh and this workflow
is orchestrated by airflow and it might
be several steps of different
steps in the airflow workflow it might
be one by spark job which creates uh
Target features
so
um answering your question it's either
one spark job or several spark jobs
orchestrated by your flow
thank you thank you
[Applause]